let's start with some debate club at
first we got grace this is Grace oh yeah
get them back buzz buzz girl this one's
so easy to me is it really haha this is
easier than crutch your smooth peanut
butter Wow well we also only make really
easy questions coming here no because
one of us easy here I was I don't pick
these I would say Canada all goddamn day
the neighbors to the north
there's no cartel up there and they're
not trying to get into hair there's a
reason so yeah it's nice there dude yeah
I got a little Eskimo hos everywhere
yeah good food nice people what else
name a couple more things this is gonna
get good about Canada yeah they got
hockey okay
okay four more things they got nice they
got maple syrup I hear Vancouver they
have Drake they have quite blender okay
JB from Toronto dude Drake is starting
to look like a frickin truck or bro like
a mixed lesbian truck or dude he's
getting there he's celebrating little
too much yeah celebrating little too
much he's had too many beef franks it
looks like you can go with Mexico listen
there's a reason I'm jumping the border
bro hmm cartel - bro think about that
it's muy peligroso in Mexico
there's too many you know that's the
thing I don't like if I'm doing cocaine
you know I don't like to be in a hot hot
area I like to be more hydrated Canada
you know I think Mexico here's here's
what I think would help we give a river
to Mexico we got a lot of rivers [ __ ]
milling around here you know
the Idaho River the you name here -
there's one yeah name the other one
Mississippi got keep going huh you going
dude mr. rivers my bad
there's tons of bad your mom made you
some tiny the rivers girl enough
there's tons of rivers bro Colorado
River already named it yeah CT baby
which was it you named it Colorado
Mississippi okay okay you going
we know I am to River Sean I do the two
mains and I'm out dude the Okeechobee
okay mister making Native American names
of cocoa a nabi Lord maybe it's maybe
it's Okeechobee dude it's a Florida
River they also have Table Rock that's a
mountain South Africa it's in Missouri
it's a river is it really yeah how big
is it can someone look it up Table Rock
River it's a river dude but dude I can
take anything and people have named
rivers at the Los Angeles River how
about that
nope not real River is it nope yes it is
Table Rock Lake in Missouri which also
the outlet goes down a river baby
a lake is not just a round river dude
you're out of your mind okay functor
River I'm starting historically with our
native rivers dude okay I'm gonna go
Hudson okay ah the Hudson is is in the
us in a lake Lake Hudson New Jersey but
it's also a river bro really I remember
Hudson River yes that's a river
he's from New Jersey it's in reverence
okay so you got one what were you saying
I'll go the Missouri River very huge
River a lot of water in it God what gave
you that the the when I said Table Rock
because that's a Missouri yeah no [ __ ]
desert oh and there's this very big in
popular river right and that goes to
Table Rock it floats in the tent no one
knows that okay I'll go also with the
Oklahoma River very huge popular outdoor
river
I'm glad you scanned over all the rivers
and came in here and that's another
popular river in the North Canadian
River and my friend max has a son named
rivers so I like that name it is a good
name actually I like the name
I forgot it I think get out of your
pants I had it written down
wait you know I was great with rivers
can we just say that can we meet
somewhere in the middle what key idea
what's up with Bane's hair she wants to
move to Mexico bang a live in Canada or
Mexico boys and let me just say first of
all this is a good this is hair coat
ladies if you want a bang grow them out
the front you know that I'm hangar yeah
if you want a bang let them hang yeah
that's it if you got them bang for the
bang you know trying to bang you let it
hot girl no this seems like a beautiful
young woman and I'm happy she reached
out to us what's her name grace oh yeah
right here grace needs to stay in Canada
she is there cuz that Sun would be a
real problem in Mexico for this young
white lady that's true now in Canyon and
Mexico you're gonna get Sun cancer okay
you're gonna get cancer from nasaan in a
tank oh yeah in Mexico in Mexico you
can't wait Kelly ante you're gonna get
you're gonna [ __ ] your pants can't drink
the water you can't drink it it's gonna
take a year to adapt to it because a
Kyle yeah you can't taste the cheese in
the past and down yeah
but also you if you get down there to
some nice areas things can be good say
Watney oh where your father lives what's
his name Morgan Morgan State - sorry but
if you guys it was here to get a camera
on there you'll see that he is obviously
Morgan Freeman it's so clear as day and
no disrespect to your paper dad but I'm
talking there maybe he's from Morgan
Freeman's from Memphis oh I'm actually
nervous
all those look into it yeah dude you got
thrown a little tower seven over there
Tower say wat nay oh so that's in Mexico
but yeah can I do look Canada I'm saying
this max Exodus coming to Canada dude a
lot of people are gonna be getting out
of America and moving to Canada I would
go Canada yep friendly people safe
peeping everyone's friendly friendly
people in Mexico - there's just still
too much there's too much
disorganization there there's too much
political unrest there's too much
violence EU get murdered your friend you
take a friend of Tijuana what do you
somebody gets murdered in your group now
you got to find somebody else to be on
your fantasy football league at the last
minute you know and you want to go to
show with your buddies walking the show
it's a donkey show you think it's a
circus adding a circuit yeah that ain't
a circus yeah you got a horn yeah kids
are front row yeah and also sometimes is
it a place you go to like the club's
down there and they're just blasting the
loudest music from like 1994 like
sometimes people want a more peaceful
environment
yeah it's violent Mexico it's just
aggressive and hot sauce doesn't go with
everything you know then so I'm taking
my ass to Canada but uh break maple
syrup end of story
but intent I would like to review this
let's table this and bring it back up in
ten years or four years it's a good
point and see how cuz I think Mexico
could catch up but they gotta tighten
some of that stuff up man I tighten some
stuff he means all stuff and why if it's
greater people leave in there all the
time you know like in their walls it's
just not good advertising it's like if
you want us to come then stay and invite
us what people would go what I would go
more if he wasn't you know always being
like oh I'm getting the [ __ ] out of
there yeah everyone goes there right
everyone
where do Mexico yes no done for vacation
everybody Cancun it's dangerous that
people start elite meeting you know
people go always thinking kun porta
viar-toe what's the other big Natalie
Holloway missing bro you know
oh no say no no yeah
Canada all day 77% of people also went
Canada as well yeah there's no cartel in
Canada baby now I would love it yeah but
listen I say we do deviate
one of these rivers down in Mexico I
think that would help out a lot that's
one thing we're doing is kind of hogging
some of the water throwing a factory
though so Nike from a factory yes an
apple in Mexico yeah throw him a factory
dude light up up I want to pair those
Betsy Ross's that came out you see that
not to see him actually they're kind of
shitty looking fuzzy yeah Capron got
pissed about him oh I did see him with
the old school flag in the back yeah
they didn't release those though did
they look at you looking at shoes bro
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching